hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about DNA
replication and how it differs in
prokaryotes versus eukaryotes remember
that prokaryotes are the cell types that
we're talking about when we're talking
about bacteria most often whereas
eukaryotes are things like animals
plants fungi eukaryote parasites algae
things like that so let's get started
first let's talk about the rate of
replication prokaryotes replicate their
DNA at a much faster rate so at a much
faster rate they're replicating it at a
rate was like 1,000 nucleotides per
second remember that nucleotides are the
building blocks of DNA whereas
eukaryotes are going more on an average
rate of like 100 nucleotides per second
this means that prokaryotes on average
can replicate their entire genome in
less than an hour
often whereas eukaryotes it can take a
few days so that can really make a big
difference and you might say why why are
prokaryotes so much faster a lot of it
has to do with the fact that they do
less DNA proofreading in other words
prokaryotes spend less time double
checking to make sure that their DNA was
replicated faithfully which means that
they do also have higher mutation rates
than eukaryotic cells
the average eukaryotic cell also has a
lot more DNA on average it's about 25
times more DNA there's obviously a lot
of variation between the amount of DNA
and eukaryotic cell and various
eukaryotic cells and then various
prokaryotic cells different species are
gonna head it around
DNA but this is an average so this is
also something that will slow down
eukaryotic replication when there's just
that much more DNA to replicate
prokaryotes also typically have a single
chromosome and it is almost always
circular so it's one circular chromosome
in a prokaryotic cell and they might
also have one or more circular plasmids
plasmids are extra chromosome only
they're not part of the actual
chromosome and there can be one or more
in a cell or none in a cell they've just
got their chromosome plasmids are
especially well known for carrying
things like genes for toxins and genes
for antibiotic resistance and genes for
other kinds of variants factors on the
other hand eukaryotes have multiple
chromosomes and they tend to be linear
now there are a couple of examples of
prokaryotes that do have linear
chromosomes the most notable one is
probably Borrelia burgdorferi which
causes Lyme disease the bacterium
Streptomyces grisliest
also has linear chromosomes that's were
streptomycin the antibiotic was first
identified but almost always prokaryotes
are circular chromosomes eukaryotes are
linear chromosomes eukaryotic DNA is
also associated with proteins known as
histones so remember that eukaryotes
have a lot more DNA in their cell and
its packaged away into the nucleus where
it's associating these histone proteins
that essentially help to organize it so
the DNA gets wrapped around these
histones in this highly organized
fashion that just kind of helps the cell
keep track of all of its DNA and keep
everything in the right place and a very
organ
iswe prokaryotes on the other hand do
not have those histone proteins
replication also of the DNA occurs in
some different compartments so in
eukaryotes it's going to be done in the
nucleus so the nucleus is where the DNA
is stored and it's also where it's
replicated on the other hand prokaryotes
DNA replication happens in the cytoplasm
this is because prokaryotes do not have
a nucleus so their chromosome is just
hanging out in the cytoplasm prokaryotes
also have one origin of replication the
origin of replication is literally where
the replication begins on the chromosome
so the point where the replication
process begins and there's just one per
circuit or chromosome in those
prokaryotes
however eukaryotes tend to have many
origins of replication so multiple
origins of replication per chromosome
and ER that eukaryotes already have
multiple chromosomes and there's
multiple origins of replication per
chromosome so it's quite a lot of places
where ever application starts the enzyme
telomerase is also only present in
eukaryotes and that's because with these
linear chromosomes it there are some
issues with replicating the ends of the
chromosomes so that every single time
that the cell divides the ends of the
chromosomes get a little bit shorter you
can see how that would be a problem
because with multiple replications you
would be losing more and more of the
chromosome and so there's an enzyme
called telomerase which basically puts
these kind of caps or ends on to the
ends of the chromosomes just to help
them be a little bit longer help protect
them these are called telomeres so
eukaryote tatin
and they have the enzyme telomerase to
make the telomeres
whereas prokaryotes they don't have T
Lanier's remember that they have this
single circular chromosome they don't
have ends to their chromosome and so
they don't need telomeres
now you might remember I told you that
there are a couple of exceptions where
some prokaryotes have linear DNA in
those prokaryotes there is some kind of
telomeric structure but how it gets
replicated at this point not a lot is
really known about that but the
telomerase enzyme is is associated just
with those eukaryotic cells mmm DNA
replication also occurs almost
continually in prokaryotes bacteria
they're almost constantly dividing as
long as there's enough certain nutrients
and as long as the environment is
favorable they're going to be dividing
pretty much continually in fact some
bacteria like e-coli they can even start
the next cell division before the
current cell division end and what I
mean by that is before a cell division
process even ends the the two cells that
haven't even fully separated yet they
can already be replicating their DNA
getting ready for the next replication
cycle so DNA replication happening
basically all the time in prokaryotes
and eukaryotes however DNA replication
is confined to a very specific part of
the cell cycle known as S phase where S
stands for synthesis and this is overall
kind of relatively a smaller part of how
the cell spends its time for most
eukaryotic cells prokaryotes also only
have one or maybe two types of DNA
polymerase polymerase is being the
enzymes that replicate the DNA whereas
most eukaryotes actually have four or
more DNA polymerases
carry out sort of subtle slightly
different functions and replicate in
different places in the eukaryotic
genome so this sort of concludes our
discussion of DNA replication and
prokaryotes and eukaryotes I have some
other videos that you might be
interested in checking out one would be
talking about these histone proteins
I've got a video on histones and DNA
packing that you might be interested in
also we talked about quite a bit of
enzymes today things like telomerase and
glimmer a so you might check out my
video on introduction to enzymes and
that is it for today thanks for watching
biology professor